murdered investigation is ongoing in
relation to the death of Miguel sturrick
who was 35 years old and stayed at Judah
Street in Glasgow
officers attended her home address
shortly after 8 40 am on Tuesday the
25th of April
and she was pronounced dead at the scene
Maria was 29 weeks pregnant and I can
confirm that sadly had unborn baby did
not survive her partner David Yates is
wanted in connection with Muriel's death
at this time we have no information to
suggest anyone else has been involved
his vehicle which was a white seat I'll
take her
was found at Morgan Park on Tuesday and
an extensive search has been ongoing at
that area since
the last confirmed sighting of David was
on Sunday evening shortly after 8 pm
his subsequent movements are unknown
after his vehicle was left at mogduk
Country Park but there is nothing to
suggest he has left that area
we will keep an open mind on this as we
continue to search the area